en france la fête de l'internet un peu
partout près d'un millier de
manifestations pour cette quatrième
édition avec comme point d'orgue à paris
la cité de la villette rendez vous
aujourd'hui de personnalités du monde
des arts et des lettres mais aussi des
passionnés des simples curieux du web
vincent furcal et alexandre de laval
éducatives et culturelles la quatrième
fête de l'internet à cette année tourner
la page de la net économie et de ses
jeunes pousses pour en privilégier
d'autres particulièrement précoce
un modèle exactement c'est un modèle des
tout premiers pas sur le réseau mondial
à l'élaboration de sites personnels en
passant par le travail de l'image et du
son la cité des sciences décline pendant
trois jours tout ce qui fait l'internet
chacun y trouve donc sa place ou presque
tous les ateliers sont pleins tout tout
le monde est derrière un ordinateur tous
les atouts les ordinateurs il ya 120 qui
sont câblés tout le monde et d'ail et
devant donc effectivement la maintenance
il ya du monde en plus qui arrive va
falloir gérer un petit peu la foulée y
aura des gens qui sont peut-être un
petit peu mécontents un succès populaire
qui ferait presque oublier que nous
sommes toujours l'un des pays européens
les moins connectés mais qu'importe la
france célèbre la toile sans complexe en
espérant des jours meilleurs quand on
est à la traîne ça oblige à presser le
pas et c'est ce que nous faisons le
gouvernement s'est engagé dans un
programme tout à fait ambitieux et nous
progressons très vite alors nous ne
sommes pas encore en tête mais dans les
trois ans qui sont devant nous nous
ferons partie du peloton de tête et dans
trois ans à quoi ressemblera internet
certains visiteurs ont déjà leur petite
idée question de flair
rast rencontre
piloté par l'ordinateur ces boîtes
noires peuvent en effet diffuser les
senteurs de l'eucalyptus au steak frites
vous allez pouvoir percevoir les odeurs
en même de la même manière que les
images elles semblent mais la fed pense
également au présent et à l'humanitaire
l'internet on a donc été reconduit cette
année une opération qui vise à collecter
du matériel informatique pour le
redistribuer aux plus déshérités